[Music]
and people of walmart news oh it's about
that girl this is your people might be
Plus these peoples are my people these
are our people deal signed about my
bills people I've never been in a
Walmart what no cuz they've always been
too far from my house I've been in Kmart
and targets and Ross's but not in still
picture you doing this but I probably
valid there you go
I'm sure once I go to a little dick oh I
get it yeah that's me can I ask who's
people are not Walmart people because I
think everyone in this room has people
who are Walmart people it's a convenient
place you can get your nails done get
all your guys check take a [ __ ] and the
bio TV one day and get McDonald's to go
your cash check you checked cash check
my cat's really clever like you get your
checks cash today
you can't blame their trust no I did
order a mini fridge there once in online
I notice we know I've heard that story
like four times
wow just wow jazz every JK video watch
it every time so his mom right Nicky
says every single video good name the
one thing they've ever bought at Walmart
unreliable Nicky can't unring key I
can't even begin to tell you all the
[ __ ] I bought at Walmart over the years
I Nicky can tell you even the one thing
you bought you never even wanted she
bought
be that one yeah thank you a bottle
Walmart me and Joe bought a trash can at
Walmart with spray paint called
wow punches by gold trash can we
couldn't finally was that your vision
board trash can you're like well I want
to saw the gold tragic we did it they
were homeless we did it for our skills
character building we thought some gold
stuff there's a gold egg carton over
there find it oh I see it yeah
it's like the I spy with my little eye
yeah oh I love those books okay anyways
reading the golden egg carton like five
times
oh my god okay submitted by Kern just
turn the wall her and like in this city
I don't know Oh Kern County County I
think maybe whatever [ __ ] go home
this is boring talking about Uncle good
to your mama lady is it was it Kern
County anyways I grabbed back Tacoma now
my Jesus uncle Marc's [ __ ] shut up
okay now I apologize on his back yeah oh
my god you turn into Joe now we're
talking about feels good that's what he
does all the time really good you
already know this right a woman drinking
wine out of a Pringles can at Walmart
has been banned from the store no she
was riding around the parking lot in
electric shock
she should be the company mascot you
know what a huge mistake no she's the
brand this is a huge huge Mary give you
the details so you guys know that right
all right no I didn't know that okay I
mean under a rock so yeah she this woman
was riding around in a parking lot for
hours starting at about 6:30 in the
morning on a Friday Wow as an electric
shopping cart that she was writing
police found her in a nearby restaurant
and told her that she had been banned
from that Walmart not arrested but she
was drinking wine out of a Pringles can
so she poured it in with Pringles in
there I don't know if pretty much goes
into yeah I bet her wine bout grows like
she was like [ __ ] it's like slowly
leaking out she's like I gotta put this
somewhere
he throws out the chips first she's
incredible I love this woman
can you imagine you're drinking [ __ ]
white out of a Pringles can
sitting on electric shopping cart like
blocks away blocks away from a Walmart
and then please go see her they're like
hey we want to let you know your bed
that wall dreams and then they ban you
for it that's [ __ ] up babe
they really [ __ ] up she should be in
every commercial like Jared was for
Subway Wow poor reference now but in
that in that repetition I want to see
her everywhere are the after know the
current okay there's anyone there motto
should be live your dreams and then
she's in the cart with the coop fringle
it's like the Sun is rising you live
your best life here at Walmart he's
amazing
do we have a picture of this one duh do
you written to be happy that's okay it's
better than this way it's better than
that kind of nation is better than like
we got all the deals there's so many
slogans you could put around that
picture you should just have a lady and
just let her sit there and sauce herself
up and medicate with that [ __ ] and then
let her just film the commercial that's
a good point I can't show you guys right
I'd be like the lady sitting in the
thing and she big and then it goes and
it's like everyday or whatever yeah
great
it was smiley faces like I can sometimes
whistle and I was matte lipstick I
remember the watch for falling prices
thing where it would just take it off
like five cents you know over that [ __ ]
yeah like watch for falling prices at
Walmart this really goes down like five
six cents goes for like three oh five -
like 296 yeah yeah yeah I'm like it's
speaking to me I'm a deals guy
I want to try this looks like I got I
got [ __ ] my body is so into that I'm
a deals guy now I was in Costa Rica
everybody's like let's get kidney stones
here that way you don't have to pay as
much for a hospital bill here my body
knows to get the deals no matter where I
go double because instead of getting a
mouth right away we had to pay our
deductible and oh no no your services in
the paper a flight home you know what
don't if you told me you like you no
matter the throws a pain in it if you're
like this is gonna cost 30 grand okay
you don't think you'd see me you would
see me get a breath of life
some people are tweeting yeah like for
example this one tweet says if we still
lived in a world with robust local media
I wouldn't be sitting here wondering
with like 15 unanswered questions about
Pringles wine lady wat wine wall that's
what you say all the time said every
time how come the news articles so short
the news media is the worst thing on the
planet
I'm asking the right questions we don't
even ever get our questions answers
disconnected
maybe you should start a news YouTube
channel yeah do it do the news but they
didn't show you on the news that's
pretty good actually I like that you're
welcome I want to count our be bald man
you didn't have cat Lauer throw to you
oh that's fun then we could not be
keeping him for no reason
cat Lauer that's pretty good oh let's
just put a talking puppet character used
to do yeah that's one more why did they
ban her though like does she steal from
Walmart
I don't think so she was writing in
Walmart's parking lot you just circle in
the parking zone that's my minute 6:00
in the morning it's not even open yeah I
think that's what Walmart's for it's
like banning the kid with no parents at
McDonald's in the playpen right like if
you go to McDonald's you're supposed to
be no shoes in the playpen anyway all
the other kids must be coughing all over
the GameCube controller
yeah they're supposed to be doing
and they ban that kid now if the kids
not taking the [ __ ] and slide then
you're like go back in the [ __ ] slide
so you take a [ __ ] like your wall your
McDonald's like come on my mom would
never let me play in that why because of
all the reasons you guys that's how you
build your immunity do I need I don't
think I missed out on anything I'm
pretty I'm pretty but she would never
let us play in that you didn't even wish
we're barefoot inside the house you had
to wear shoes all the time
maybe that's why you know you never knew
the pleasures of jumping it into a pit
full of balls only after my sister let
me do it in chucky cheese but never
mcdonald's never hey my favorite playpen
thingy whatever and the fast food
restaurant was Burger King the one in
Bellflower they used to have is dole
fast [ __ ] place that if I felt like
an entire castle it was gigantic
obviously for like a little kid it was
insane but compared to other play places
like other shits on them this Burger
King one was like there's like the one
to throw up in and like there's no
better wanna throw up no super long
slide that I've got like a lesson in
eternity with awesome I loved it
you know what sucks about that going
back as an adult do like calm and then
you see this you see the slide it's
probably as big as like like the ceiling
up there that's pretty tall for yes so
like I say but as a kid where it's like
man I was like going forever he probably
got rid of it cuz ten kids probably bad
on that so they actually gonna be
changed everything because it was really
dangerous
you went back I think I was like maybe
like 19 or something when I saw it I was
driving by and I asked my family member
I still lived around the area they're
like yeah it was too dangerous a lot of
people kept getting hurt gee you haven't
lived until you go down a slide into a
ball pit and the balls they're all kind
of wet Oh God
ill and you're like what was that but
then you're like oh this is fun and then
you go again
oh [ __ ] no I'm never gonna live you
haven't lived you until you're like in
one of those little [ __ ] things that
up the purple tunnel face yeah and then
you see a bunch of throw-up here
why are they so much grow
San Diego one there everyone was in
every one of them never stop being there
one do not dry dry throw up like you
could chisel it off of the phone I never
experienced that I was still getting in
those tubes with huge like wait maybe
not I don't know do you go in a [ __ ]
hazmat suit she had a full [ __ ] gear
on no Tiger has a full oh there you go
that's good no I don't give a [ __ ] about
thing
[Music]